rbs la saint valentin n'oubliez pas
d'avoir un mot gentil demain sous peine
de réprimande à cette occasion voici les
résultats d'un sondage sur notre
sexualité déclaration honnête ou
légèrement arrondi au chiffre supérieur
les français adultes tous âges confondus
déclarent faire l'amour
une fois tous les trois jours en moyenne
frédéric vion nathalie gallet le french
lover serait-il fatigué un seul sondage
et c'est l'image de la france qui en
prend un coup
notre pays jadis réputée pour
l'endurance de ses amants ne serait en
fait qu'un repaire de vente à et je peux
le faire deux trois fois par jour
à 44 ans je vais pas non plus me porter
mais bon souvent quoi
bien dans la moyenne
bien sûr qu'il se vantait ce que les
femmes hommes
la ville
parce que pour faire croire qu'ils sont
très viril et social
hélas c'est vous madame qui avait raison
derrière les états unis et même la grèce
notre pays ne se classent plus que 7e au
regard du nombre annuel de rapports
sexuels sans 17 par an soit un tous les
trois jours
un chiffre qui de plus est sans doute
surestimé les pays latins ont tendance à
sur pondérer leur vie sexuelle et les
pays asiatiques au contraire la modérer
la raison en est simple sont des raisons
culturelles
de même lorsqu'on a des rapports hommes
femmes lorsque les français explique
qu'ils ont 17 partenaires sexuels dans
leur vie et les femmes que neuf
en attendant ce légitimement à croire un
peu plus les femmes que les hommes nous
dire et de faire l'amour à trois en
matière de fantasmes les français sont
sages ils voudraient faire l'amour sur
la plage dans un jacuzzi ou une forêt
quant au physique du partenaire ils
comptent moins à les entendre que sa
personnalité
vantard et menteur en plus